am freitag findet in der maria theresien
kaserne ein großer festakt statt der
generalstabschef robert rieger wird
verabschiedet allerdings nicht in den
ruhestand sondern nach brüssel für die
gegend ist es trotzdem ja bewegen weil
es der abschied ist natürlich von vielen
kameraden mitarbeiter und
mitarbeiterinnen die mich teilweise über
jahrzehnte unterstützt haben und die
nicht sehr verbunden bin andererseits
auch die freude dass ich noch eine
funktion übernehmen darf im
internationalen bereich eben als
vorsitzender des militärausschusses der
europäischen union wo ich hoffe für die
sicherheit europas noch einen beitrag
leisten zu können liga chef des
generalstabs die vergangenen vier jahre
lang eine durchaus turbulente zeit
häufiger regierungsumbildung an carola
krise unter immer noch während die krieg
russlands gegen die ukraine für
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
hat brieger mit seiner besonnenen art
diese krisen so gut es ging gemeistert
geprägt vor allem auch durch einen
general von einem besonderen schlag der
in all diesen herausforderungen immer
besonnen agiert
krieger die in seiner zeit als chef des
generalstabs unter vier
verteidigungsminister vor klaudia tanner
thomas starlinger johann luif und mario
kunasek der in 20 18 in die chefetage
holt
dann kommt das gar zum ausdruck und ich
glaube an afrika hat seine funktion
positive spuren im bundesrat auch
hinterlassen und wird auch in brüssel
auseinander welche eigenschaften man als
generalstabschef in unruhigen zeiten wie
diesen unbedingt haben sollte bringt
krieger so auf den punkt der wichtig ist
beharrlichkeit in der verfolgung der
ziele eine gewisse äquidistanz zu
zur politik das heißt loyalität
dem staatswesen der republik gegenüber
und
was er auch braucht ist meiner ansprache
gesagt hat ein quäntchen vor tun ohne
dass der erfolg nicht eintritt und
verteidigungsministerin klaudia tanner
verabschiedet general robert briner nur
mit den besten wünschen ich wünsche ihm
weiterhin so besonders einschreiten das
auch immer wieder auf das verständnis an
der politik jetzt in einem größeren
sinne in der europäischen union stößt
zum sicherheit zur sicherheit dann in
wahrheit auch ganz europa so dass er
auch privat brüssel seine veränderung
das darf man auch nicht vergessen und
das ist schon eine sehr große
verantwortung trägt das auch eine
persönliche erfüllung finden kann